Hello everybody and welcome tooooooooooo ...
skrattar du forlorar du mannen, YouTube's favorite show. That's right everybody to join this challenge, which I've clearly lost
Oopsie, all you gotta do is to leave a like and hit the bell button. That's all you got to do and you're in that's right
Now, let's begin the challenge. If you laugh, you will recieve a massive di*k in your a*s
All right. Clearly you two need therapy. So step into my office
*anticipating silence*
no-trap no-trap no-trap trap
dont trap us please
don't trap us please. All right, so
*pew*
Great I mean he solved couples therapy and now they don't have to do it as a couple anymore
Thank you for laughing at that joke, that was really funny. I know
Oh my god I've seen this
Kind of want to see Shrek get married now
It's kind of sad that we will never see that happen. People look at the problems in the world. But what about Shrek's problem? Oh
Oh my gah...
stay away
X69
Arghh
LilTay is a princess what happened to Lil Tay
She just changed her style now grown woman now that's such a weird caption. She's still 9 like what da (fuck)
Do you have a... Do you happen to have a toilet paper on that side, cause I'm all out right here
Oh
You, you're giving me the whole role?
Oh sh*t,
You... You can have this than
It's just like.. thank you you know
Comradeship nothing like two brothers
Exchanging goods and deeds and valuables that's inspiring
That doesn't make me laugh, that makes me inspired. There is hope for humanity
Oh noooo...
Ohhhhh noooooo...
Guy 2: What the hell... who would do this?
Guy 1: WHYYY? Guy 2: why did you do this?
Guy 1: WHYYYYY? What the f**kkk.. WHYY?
I think I discovered my kink, everyone.
Think I discovered my new kink everyone please do send me more photos
Please do send me more photos
If there is. I don't see why they're going all "noooo" I was going internally "Yes more, please"
Some car cars 2 and beans. Wow, that sounds like a fantastic combination
Two of my favorite things. Just don't go to the cinema and enjoy them
Big problem if you do
Morning school sign is supposed to read "sewage plant field trips are today..."
So can either of you explain why it now reads...
EEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEE
Yeah, the E meme still kicking it apparently still living - still having a good time, great
Oh my god, I've seen this video soo many times
Im gana miss the bus
Guys, wait for me, I'm comin'
Oh god, I don't wanna miss the bus
This is you laugh you lose not you cringe you lose regardless, thank you.
I know what men can do when they're angry
YA DID YOU DRINK MY MOUNTAIN DEW?
DID YOU DRINK MY MOUNTAIN DEW?!
LEMME SMELL YOUR BREATH
LEMME SMELL YOUR BREATH!! (SNIFF)
Was that boogy... was that was that boogie2988?
Dude that looked exactly like boogie2988. I know I know he likes mountain dew as well. He told me
I've seen this one, but I don't remember the punchline
That's why that's why
oh, My god, they're getting too old. I'm getting too old for this memes. goddammit
Where's the crying PewDiePie, come on
no, not the pig
(hearth breaking moments)
(RIP pig, you will never be forgotten)
awww, he became a pork
(legit Fortnite gameplay)
I Need to find that... I mean that version of fortnite looks fantastic Wow, finally
I might be playing fortnite now. Why do I look like I have no ice
What is this happening jesus. boss you killed a child
amazing, mission complete (pewds laughing like an idiot(a cute one))
that right there is why you're the best, boss
the One and only
Oh My god you killed the children
Amazing job. You get an S rating
Fantastic - Trump
boss you killed a child
amazing, mission complete. that right there is why you're the best boss. This is why Japanese games are the best
I Don't need another version of the Wii one. Thank you. I will not accept this I say no. I say no to this one
I don't need a Korean version of it
Jesus Christ man, it's not just Western civilization. That is ruin. It's come clear now.
Wait, wait a minute. Wait
wait
Excuse me. Why are you searching sexy Garfield? I mean, why wouldn't you, he is pretty attractive out of all cartoons
I've always had a fond interest in Garfield. Sorry. I thought we were admitting our darkest secrets
i've never understood this meme, i don't get it.
meme plus meme does not equal meme
oh oh triple up
goddammit I'm so ashamed that I laughed at that goddamnit
Why did I laugh at that? Why did I sink So low? I say that I don't like overly loud and obnoxious
And Here I am laughing at it. I'm a hypocrite. I'm a fool. I'm a peasant I'm scum. I'm little scum
scumbag
Anyway, let's watch some more clips
E (EEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEE)
Just let the E die, please, he's already dead actually I didn't mean for that I was insensitive
Hey Vsauce, Michael here. Take a look at this. Mm-hmm
Simple enough right? But watch what happens next
I Knew it I know it. I know it. What's the heck is this thing?
Ladies and gentlemen, we got him
We went from mother and son to father and daughter
(Ali-B intro)
okay fine that was a good Ali-A. I havn't seen a good Ali-A meme in awhile
Haha loud noises not funny stop doing it or else. Errrrrrr
or aaaaaaaaaaah. Is that funny to you? Hi, why'd you laugh then?
Wait, What?
Be careful, what are you gonn...
(chuckles)
Why am I laughing nothing funny has happened
ohhhh..   Ahahahahah
that was good. That was actually good
Now you ruined it
stop. just stop you need to know when to end them
alright well speaking of knowing when to end it i'm gonna end this video here if you enjoy watching leave a like and
I'll see you next what leave a like if you loose and if you like if you lost and
Let me know if you lost in the comments. Let me know now
I will have to go and I'll see you tomorrow with another video. What am I going to do tomorrow?
Well, you're just gonna have to wait until then to find out
ASS (Animal Super Squad) gameplay